the Joe Rogan experience Eddy said it
kept popping and Hoyle is just dealing
with the pain like right there that's
the oh my god that his life
Terrance mental fortitude man you know
meant that whole family is savages I
mean there's never been a family that's
revolutionized martial arts the way the
Gracie family did inhaler was the most
successful of all the Gracie's when it
came to competition he was a multiple
time world champion of course he is look
at his [ __ ] man
Eddie Bravo's mangling his knee and he
won't tap and Eddie's telling him just
tap man he's like it's fine it's normal
he's like dude you leg just pop five
times he's like it's normal like he's
happening again
Eddie's got him wrapped up nasty and
this is some [ __ ] Eddie invented yeah
that's crazy about all of this
I mean who i lured to his credit just
rather did his knee torn apart than lose
was the last time the Indian came out
Eddie probably hours ago we were just
talking on the phone the other day and I
was driving to this area with the
cellphone was about to cut out he was
telling me some crazy conspiracy and I
was like bruh bruh I love you I gotta go
I love you too man I'm sorry
Shuji you're off I love to be a woman so
crazy
oh my god he loves conspiracies he loves
conspiracies like it's like his family
number one jiu-jitsu number two
conspiracies what's the new one maybe
his friends number three and that
conspiracies hope everybody can do it
everybody see I don't know too deep
about it but even [ __ ] a chimp could
tell you dog marshals look man that guy
Bill Clinton flew with that guy 26
confirmed times 26 it might be 28 but 26
confirmed times I read that on my bride
and follow with my mother
26 times now how's this guy fly with
Bill Bill Clinton flew with a pedophile
26 times over the period of some Island
right years [ __ ] Island the old [ __ ]
Island that's what everybody else called
it or how to defend against suicide
I'm loving these bees red yeah they snap
that guy's [ __ ] neck man is that Eddie
they snap that guy's [ __ ] they said
his neck was fractured he said how do
you do that hanging yourself yeah yeah
how do you hang yourself in jail dude
they come out eventually did even
Michael Shermer who's like a
professional skeptic he's the editor of
skeptics magazine okay he says probably
conspiracy even him yeah he said what
the cameras are down the cameras weren't
working they killed that dude no one's
talking about it
mmm no everybody news I mean there's
that leak where that ABC reporter was
saying that ABC squashed the story three
years ago that was just so Hillary was
on forever no and he kinda acts it
I joked around with her yeah but she
laughed about it yeah I thought it was
one of those um what do you call the
thing that deep fakes mm but it was real
well here's what's crazy she knew that
guy yeah she knew that guy and that guy
was most likely murdered in jail hmm and
she was laughing about it yeah like cuz
Trevor Noah said how did you kill
Jeffrey upstair but she's like ha ha ha
but that's like imagine if you knew
someone like and your husband was flying
around with that guy and this is like a
someone you know you got to know pretty
well like you've hung out with him at
cocktail parties like you know maybe
you've known him for years and then that
guy gets murdered and then somebody asks
you how did you murder I mean you start
laughing you gotta be weird you gotta be
a cruel heartless person to think that's
funny that's sweet about it weird she
did that same thing with one Qaddafi
stuff that was even like that was
different though because that wasn't a
joke yeah did she said we came we saw he
died ha ha
but out someone that wasn't her friend
someone who wasn't a friend right this
was someone who she knew and you know
Trevor no and listened the way The Daily
Show works for sure they told they told
her beforehand yeah it couldn't sprung
that on no way oh wait you don't spring
[ __ ] on Hilary goddamn Clinton had all
the questions so yeah that's a should we
be late
like ahahaha she's got to know you
respect her she's got I mean there's no
way she's coming on that show unless she
knows everything's gonna be ok so when
they they brought that up and she starts
laughing she knew that [ __ ] was coming
guarantee you guarantee you guarantee
you they they're not free balling on
that show come on later on I'm sure to
come out later on some people know too
much man yeah way too much it probably
will be one of those decades later
things we find out you know that some
some guy on his deathbed says he killed
Epstein yeah cuz Clinton paid him off
you know who the [ __ ] knows who knows
who that guy who knows what that guy
knew I mean that guy that that guy was a
professional blackmailer you know I
don't know who he worked for I have no
idea is more like [ __ ] I might just be
the tip of the iceberg whole shitload of
things we have no idea yes yeah yeah
surprise all that kind of stuff gets
into politics as well with like um sex
traffic you don't want no it's like
right well I think we're billionaires
you can get a guy like that like here's
a lot of these guys this is my thoughts
a lot of these guys are freaks and then
they're in the public eye so they have
to maintain proper pose we know Bill
Clinton during the 90s in particular
there's no internet [ __ ] he was [ __ ]
like just [ __ ] up a storm he's a wild
man and you know and there's a few
alleged rapes you know yes alleged
sexual mean I don't know I wasn't there
but there's women that are accusing him
of sexual assault and rape so you got
the Monica Lewinsky thinks you know he's
a free is getting his dick sucked by 20
bust him he's like well as to what I
thought sexual relations were
but you got to think there's a lot of
those dudes out there yeah that's why
they get into politics in the first
place all in their 60s so they got into
politics in the [ __ ] 80s and the 70s
they got into politics is they wanted a
[ __ ] they wanted to be the king they
wanted to be the guy with all the power
they wanted to be the Alpha and so then
all of a sudden the rules change because
of the internet so then they got to
figure out Jesus I can't do anything
anymore what the [ __ ] you so what they
do is they find a guy's gonna take him
to an island where there's no rules
I am Jeffrey Epstein he's got this place
he brings in these girls from
Czechoslovakia and they suck your dick
into your head explodes let's do it
Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada you're on
the court in the [ __ ] the boat ahead
is the island with Clinton you know
Island
where'd you get that Island no one knows
ever know you buy an island you don't
the intelligence agencies give you money
to give you an ion they set it up
someone from some agency whether it's
Mossad or CIA or whoever the [ __ ] it was
they had a concerted effort most likely
to try to bring these creepers and bring
them over there attempt them pushing
them and he know how to do it I think
they probably do it as well as like
having [ __ ] over them yes that way they
can have like they can get them to do
things for them
exactly decisions bills that need to be
passed you know [ __ ] we should like
[Applause]